and the last video in exponential
functions we saw that functions of the
form y is equal to some number to the X
say Y is equal to 3x was what we used in
the last video we saw that these grow
very very very quickly so the shape of
the graph that we got in the last video
looks something like this it looked
something like this gets very close to 0
slowly approaches away from 0 and then
BAM starts to explode and this of course
is when X is equal to 0 so the y
intercept there is y is equal to 1 but
the important thing is it just grows
super fast but this was the case where
the base in the exponential function is
greater than 1 you know here it's 3 if
it's 2 it'll still grow quickly if it
was Ted it would grow even faster what I
want to talk a little bit about in this
video and really just introduce you to
the idea is the notion of an exponential
decay function so this is an exponential
growth function an exponential decay
function has essentially as its base a
number less than 1 so an example of an
exponential decay function would be y is
equal to 1/3 to the X power this would
be exponential exponential decay and
notice another way I could write this
1/3 is the same thing as 3 to the
negative 1 so it's 3 to the negative 1
to the X power I could also write this
as 3 to the negative x power this and
this are equivalent and that's another
interesting way to think about
exponential decay functions it could
either be kind of a standard positive
exponent with a base that's less than 1
or you could have a base larger than 1
but you're going to have a negative x as
the exponent but let's plot this just to
get the general shape and the shape will
always be consistent I'm going to do it
for one-third but it's going to have a
similar shape for 1/2 or for 1/10 or for
1/100 it'll just be scaled up or down so
let's plot a few so let's have some X
values and let's have some Y values so
let's say let's start with some small
values so let's say that X is equal to
negative
three well what is 1/3 to the negative
three power that's the same 1/3 to the
negative 3 that's the same thing as 3 to
the third power which is equal to 81
let's do another point what about
negative 2 1/3 to the negative 2 power
is the same thing as 1 over sorry is
it's equal to 1 over 1/3 squared which
is the same thing as 3 squared you just
take the inverse of the number get rid
of the negative and that is equal to
equal to 9 oh I got this one wrong up
here 3 cubed isn't 81 that's 3 to the
4th 3 times 3 times 3 is 27 27 my brain
is malfunctioning what about when X is
equal to negative 1 then you have 1 3 to
the negative 1 power 1 3 to the negative
1 which is just 3 what about when X is
equal to 0 when X is equal to 0 remember
anything to the zeroth power is 1 and
then let's go to a couple of larger
numbers when X is equal to 1 what is y
1/3 to the 1 power is 1/3 let's do one
more when X is equal to 2 we have 1/3
squared which is 1/9 so let's plot this
exponential decay function right here I
want to draw it reasonably neatly
reasonably neatly and all of these
values once again are positive because
our base was positive so it looks like
that will start so let me go so let's
say that this is 10 20 30 and let's
start at negative 3 negative 2 negative
1 0 1 2 so when X was negative 3 y was
27 when X was negative 3 y was 27 right
about there
when X was negative 2 y was 9 which is
right about there when X is negative 1 Y
is 3
right about there X 0 Y is 1 X is 1 Y is
1/3 and so we decline like this we
decline oh let me draw it a little bit
neater than that these the K functions
are harder for me to draw that's well
let me do it one more maybe I'll draw it
this way
draw it in reverse order now that's even
worse
one more shot I think you get the
general idea that's my best shot right
there so you see a decay function it's
kind of reversed around the y axis we
start from a large quantity and we decay
very very very quickly so in either case
exponential functions whether we have
exponential growth or exponential decay
and we make sure that you understand
this growth applies to this thing up
here this is exponential decay that
either way when in exponential functions
things happen quickly now use using what
we know about exponential decay
functions let's do an action 'el an
actual actual word problem let me read
it here it says a person is infected by
a bacterial infection bacterial
infection and they say when he goes to
the doctor the population of bacteria is
2 million so at the start he's got 2
million little critters 2 million
bacteria 2 million bacteria the doctor
prescribes an antibiotic which kills
bacteria that reduces the bacteria to
one-fourth of its population each day or
that reduces the bacterial population to
one-fourth of its size each day so we
have the antibiotic anti biotic and it
cuts down the population so if on it
cuts down I guess we could say reduces
population to one-fourth of of I guess
you could say the previous population
previous population each
day so they asked us of a couple of
things draw the graph of the size of the
bhakti of the bacterial population
against time in days so let's draw this
so day and then population population so
let's say on day 0 before you went to
the doctor your population is going to
be 2 million now on day 1 what happens
on day 1 you've taken their antibiotic
right the antibiotic is starting right
there so it reduces it to 1/4 of your
previous population so now your
population is going to be 1/4 times 2
million which is equal to what 500 equal
to 500,000 then on day 2 what happens on
day 2 is going to be 1/4 of this it's
going to be 1/4 of your previous day 1/4
of 1/4 of your preview of that 2 million
of that 2 million so it's 1/4 of this
500,000 which is 125,000 I think you are
starting to see the pattern that's
emerging on day 3 what's it going to be
it's going to be 1/4 times this thing so
it's going to be 1/4 times this 1/4
times 1/4 times 1/4 times 2 million
which is essentially 125,000 divided by
4 but the important thing is I want you
to see this pattern in general in
general the population at day n let me
write this in a new color the population
the population on day n is going to be
equal to what it's going to be equal to
1/4 to the N power right this is day n
on the third day was 1/4 to the 3rd
power times 2 million on day 2 is 1/4 to
the 2nd power on day 1 is 1/4 to the
first power on day 0 there is actually
1/4 to the 0 of power right that's 1
so it's 1/4 to the nth power times our
starting population times 2
a million times 2 million and if we were
to graph it if we were to graph it using
at least just the points that we have
here we're only going to be dealing with
positive X's so on day zero we start at
two million so let's let's say this is a
million so in day zero we're at two
million on day one on day one we're 1/4
of that so let's say that's 1 million so
then that is 500,000 on date two we're
1/4 of this so this is 250,000 that's
125,000 and then on day 3 we're 1/4 of
that so you see the population of our
bacteria really goes down very quickly
never gets quite to zero we're always
going to have some bacteria well
eventually you're gonna have one
bacteria and you're going to get the
antibiotic and it's going to have a 1/4
chance of hitting it so maybe eventually
you'll get to zero but it slowly gets to
zero but the absolute number decreases
very very fast now they're also asked us
find the size of the bacterial
population ten days after the drug was
first taken so after 10 days so that's
just n is equal to 10 so it's going to
be equal to 1/4 to the 10th power times
2 million now let's take our calculator
out to calculate this so let's take 1/4
to the 10th power to the tenth power
that's equal to this very small number
times 2 million 1 2 3 1 2 3 is equal to
we're only going to have 1.9 bacteria
after the tenth day so we're going to
have this is going to be equal to one
point nine bacteria so pretty much most
of the bacteria is gone after the tenth
or by the tenth day